okay before we move on to other topics
today I do want to follow up with a sort
of side story related to Donald Trump's
tariffs 25% tariffs on steel 10% steyr a
tariff on aluminum that he announced
late last week the overwhelming majority
of Trump policy during the first 13
months of his presidency has been a
combination of just sort of flat-out bad
policy combined with cronyism and the
filling of the swamp the very swamp that
Trump promised to drain and there's an
element of the steel and aluminum
tariffs that also point in that
direction we've already gone over the
policy side of it right I told you in
the first segment today we're not gonna
win trade Wars Trump is wrong that
they're easy to win
terrible economics maybe a total lack of
understanding of economics by Donald
Trump now we get to the possible
cronyism part do you remember the name
Carl Icahn he was once an advisor to
Trump he's a known Trump friend he's a
known businessman and he's worth about
17 billion dollars Icahn is either
incredibly lucky or might have been
trading on inside information because he
happened to sell 31 million dollars
worth of stock and a company that very
directly relies on steel as a source
material just a few days before Donald
Trump announced that he'd be putting a
25 percent tariff on imported steel and
a 10 percent tariff on aluminum as well
and the company in question is Manitowoc
company they manufacture those huge
construction cranes and lifting
solutions which include the cranes you
often see on boat yards that lift
containers so steel nevertheless is a
major major deal for them and as a
result of Donald Trump's announcement
Manitowoc shares were down 16 percent
from their February 22nd price which is
the day that Icahn decided to sell his
stock but you might say even though
Trump didn't announce the tariff until
after February 22nd it was actually
February 16th when Trump's Commerce
Secretary Wilbur Ross called for the
tariff so it's possible that Icahn sort
of seeing the writing on the wall on
February 16th
decided to start selling as a result of
that public recommendation from Wilbur
Ross well that's true but if you
actually go back and look at the data
icons started selling his shares of
Manitowoc on February 12th four days
before
Wilbur Ross's recommendation went public
now if you're a skeptic and you should
be right anyone who wants to thoroughly
explore what's going on here would say
hold on a second David was Icahn
regularly buying and selling shares of
Manitowoc leading up to that point
because if he was it's not really a big
deal that he decided to sell a whole
bunch because maybe he had been buying
and selling big bunches of it for a long
time
great question glad you asked before
mid-february
Icahn had not been actively buying or
selling the stock he had no purchases or
sales of the stock for at least three
years dating back to January of 2015
he's already a big swamp guy called a
special advisor by Trump but he didn't
clear up his endless conflicts of
interest before accepting the position
with Trump so he ended up resigning
right before a New Yorker article was
gonna totally expose him
he admits he occasionally still talks to
Donald Trump he did not buy or sell any
shares of manitowoc requiring a
disclosure for at least three years and
then he gets rid of 31 million in shares
days before major tariffs on steel are
announced either this guy really has the
great business sense that I guess maybe
made him 17 billion to begin with or
he's a rancid swamp dweller here and I
was thinking as I read these articles
about this about house of cards there's
this character Raymond tusk
who's friends with Frank Underwood and
something about Frank tusk and Carl
Icahn they really seem to be a similar
in many ways and there are trumpets
defending Trump by saying nobody with
Carl icons net worth 17 billion would be
dumb enough to do this over 31 million
dollars because they'd know someone
would notice I actually disagree Trump
and everybody around him for his entire
13 months
in office really for several years even
during the campaign they've been acting
in ways where you would think no one
would act this way because I'm sure they
know they wouldn't get away with it
right but know that they do it anyway it
doesn't seem to matter to them and in
many ways they all probably think that
they can get away with this stuff will
we ever know the truth I hope so
I don't I don't know that we will but
Carl Icahn hell of a guy I want to talk
briefly about a fantastic personal
wellness app called well Tory it's an
app that's really changing the game when
it comes to monitoring certain aspects
of your health from home we all know
that the US healthcare system is in
crisis and it has been for a long time
Obama care cut the uninsured population
roughly in half but millions of
Americans still don't have health
coverage over 12% of the country as of
the end of 2017 and something that
doctors and health care professionals
advocate for which is important for
people who have health insurance but is
especially relevant in the context of
the number of uninsured Americans is
self-care self-care meaning any measures
you can take at home on your own to stay
healthy and prevent future illness a big
part of this is making healthy lifestyle
choices but also monitoring your own
health so that you're better aware of
what's going on with your body and so
that you can make more informed
decisions about your lifestyle and
monitoring yourself can encompass many
different things but definitely one
excellent tool that can help you stay on
top of your day-to-day health is well
Tory well Tory is a wellness app that
provides users with critical information
about their health stress productivity
and performance we all want to start the
day with plenty of energy and maintain a
certain level of consistent energy
throughout the day and many people's
productivity and energy levels can
suffer from things like stress or lack
of sleep and much of the time people are
not even fully aware of how or
these factors are affecting them on a
daily basis and this can have an adverse
effect on so many aspects of our lives
anything from our productivity at work
relationships with the people in our
lives
that's where well Tori can be a useful
tool it's a mobile app that helps people
keep track of their stress and fatigue
which in turn can help you combat stress
and fatigue because you can only manage
what you can measure
well Tori uses scientifically validated
techniques to measure your stress and
energy levels using heart rate
variability algorithms it's actually
really cool the app measures your heart
rate just by having you put your finger
on your phones camera lens I didn't even
know that was possible to be honest well
Tory takes this information and uses it
to give you helpful feedback about ways
to improve your stress and energy levels
they use your data to give you
customized tips about how you might be
able to adjust your lifestyle to benefit
everything from your sleep and your
exercise to your diet and your working
habits and everyone is different your
solutions have to be catered to you
personally for instance not everyone
needs the same amount of sleep that's
why well Tory takes your heart rate
measurements and gives you tips about
how much sleep you should be getting
based on its algorithms that analyze
your energy levels what kind of exercise
works best for you
well Tory will tell you and not only
that just the mere activity of
monitoring your body and your lifestyle
on a daily basis has been shown to get
people to adjust their behaviors because
you're actually taking an active role in
observing yourself
download the app there's a link in the
description below this video it's
completely free it has a great rating on
both the Google Play Store and the
iTunes App Store and well Tory
integrates with over 50 fitness apps and
gadgets but no other devices are
required so manage your energy be aware
of your stress and how it affects you
make the most out of every day thanks to
well Tory for sponsoring this video well
Tory makes it easy to do these things